este ejercicio es exactamente lo que
vimos en el último vídeo pero ahora en
vez de tomar la t de 0 a 2 pi vamos a
tomar la nuestro parámetro t entre 0
y vi así que básicamente estamos tomando
media circunferencia verdad si dibujamos
aquí el plano xy
muy bien aquí están los ejes el eje x el
eje y entonces ahora nuestro camino o
nuestra curva no va a ser una
circunferencia sino si pensamos a t como
el ángulo de esta circunferencia estamos
tomando entre 0 y pi que es solo media
circunferencia entonces no es un camino
cerrado no podemos en este caso decir
que la integral siendo f conservativa
pues que sea 0 porque para eso
necesitamos que la curva sea cerrada y
en este caso no lo es pero veamos si
podemos utilizar alguna otra técnica que
habíamos visto en otros vídeos pero
bueno si ponemos a efe en su forma
vectorial ésta sería las dos entradas de
f las dos componentes de f y entonces f
de xy es no es otra cosa más que x
cuadrada massieu cuadrada y esto
multiplicando al vector y más
2x y 2 x por el vector j correcto ahora
bien
deere es la diferencial de nuestra curva
esto será igual a de x y más de jota
verdad ahora si vemos el producto punto
entre estas dos entonces tendremos que
ese punto de r es justamente justamente
lo que tenemos como integrando en la
integral de línea sobre la curva se
verdad es esto obtendríamos lo de aquí
esto que estamos en marcando así que si
multiplicamos los términos que tienen y
obtenemos x cuadrada más de cuadrada de
x que es este primero y luego 2x y por d
ye que es este segundo así que nuestra
integral sobre la curva de f punto de r
es realmente lo que queríamos calcular
inicialmente ahora nos preguntamos esta
f
es un campo conservativo es decir tiene
algún potencial o en otros términos
existe una f mayúscula tal que
su gradiente sea nuestro campo vectorial
efe que elegimos al inicio entonces
según vimos en el último vídeo y vamos a
repetirlo una vez más si tuviéramos esta
condición la integral sobre cualquier
curva cerrada sería cero pero éste no es
una curva cerrada lo que sí sabemos es
que por ser conservativo la integral es
independiente de la trayectoria que le
que elegimos perfecto así que de hecho
sabemos quién es esta integral verdad
esto es efe y cómo se va de cero a ti
pues entonces vamos a tener que evaluar
de cero a ti verdad así que esto será
fdp - efe de cero o si queremos
escribirlo en términos de xy de y pues
entonces aquí donde lo tenemos aquí en
vez de pi vamos a poner equis o va a ser
nuestro nuestro valor ente así que esto
será efe de equis en coma y en pi
y luego restamos efe de x en 0 x en 0,0
verdad si quisiéramos escribir efe como
como esta forma ahora la f mayúscula es
una función escalar verdad así que
podríamos decir que estos son
simplemente las tres en las que vamos a
evaluar a x de ahí perfecto ahora sólo
falta evaluarlo en estos dos puntos
ya tendremos el valor de la de la
integral porque esto es independiente
del camino de hecho no necesitamos saber
cuál era la curva de verdad entonces de
ser así su integración de línea es
independiente del camino ya no lo va a
repetir una vez más esto esto ya debería
haber quedado claro y ahora lo que vamos
a intentar hacer es exactamente lo mismo
que hicimos en el vídeo anterior si ya
lo viste bueno puede ser un poco
monótono pero no nunca está de más
repetirlo para que quede claro cómo se
resuelve el problema entonces sabemos
que la parcial de esta f mayúscula
respecto de x debe ser la primera
entrada x cuadrada massieu cuadrada si
es que es un potencial del campo
vectorial
efe integrando respecto a x tenemos que
fx y es igual a x al cubo entre 3 que la
integral de x cuadrada y luego más xy
cuadrada verdad todo esto es resultado
de integrar respecto de x y agregamos
una constante que puede ser cualquier
función de ye porque al derivar respecto
de x esa función de yesa
y ahora la parcial de f respecto de y
será la segunda componente del campo
vectorial esto será igual a 2x
ahora volvemos a hacer lo mismo si
tomamos la integral de esta expresión
respecto de y tendremos que fx y es
igual a la integral de 2x que es x ye
cuadrada más cualquier función que
dependa exclusivamente de x verdad y
ahora estas dos expresiones que
obtuvimos deben ser iguales vamos a
procurar que coincidan así que coinciden
en esta x y cuadrada coinciden en eso
del lado derecho tenemos una función que
depende de x y del lado izquierdo
podemos encontrar esta x cúbica entre 3
y ahora la f de y tiene que ser cero
porque del lado derecho no encontramos
una función que dependa de iu así que
tendremos que nuestra f mayúscula es x
cúbica entre 3 + xy cuadrada perfecto
ahora qué es lo que sigue
de nuestro campo vectorial es un campo
conservativo y está f mayúscula es el
potencial así que la integral de 0 api
de nuestro campo conservativo a lo largo
de ese simplemente es evaluar efe en los
extremos así que hagámoslo bueno x era
coche no vete y ese no dt voy a
escribirlo acá abajo así que a x es
igual a coseno dt y es igual a seno dt
así que x evaluada en 0 será x en 0 será
coseno de cero que es 1 y perdón x en
pib va a ser coseno de pib que es menos
1 ahora sigue ya en cero
valdez en 90 que es cero y en pi es
igual al seno de pi que es cero perfecto
ahora hay que evaluar efe en estos
valores que obtuvimos nuestra integral
entonces vamos a simplificar la la
integral sobre c df punto de r será
igual a quien a efe
evaluada en x en pi como hippie es decir
en menos 1 coma
y vale 0 entonces es f evaluada en menos
10 - efe evaluada x en 0 que en este
caso es uno coma
valuado en cero que en este caso es cero
perfecto ahora tienes esta función es
evaluada en menos 10
este término de aquí como ya habíamos
mencionado son los xy es evaluadas en pi
acuérdense muy bien de esto ahora sólo
basta que evaluemos la función en esos
dos puntos y esto va a ser muy fácil
verdad
x es menos 1 así que si sustituimos en
la función f en realidad tenemos menos 1
al cubo que es menos 1 entre 3
simplemente tenemos menos un tercio
menos un tercio y ahora x es menos uno
que vale cero así que cualquier cosa por
cero es cero así que ese término
desaparece vamos a ignorarlo y ahora
vamos a restar restamos efe evaluada en
10 ahora x vale 11 al cubo es 1 y entre
3 pues es un tercio y ahora x por 0 al
cuadrado lo que sea bueno eso es 0
verdad así que si hacemos esta suma ya
hemos terminado porque tenemos menos dos
tercios y de nuevo esto fue
independiente del camino realmente no
tuvimos que molestarnos que con los
cosenos los senos y demás esto
simplemente tenemos que encontrar quién
es nuestro campo perdón nuestro
potencial de nuestro campo vectorial y
evaluamos en los extremos